former CIA officer Frederic it's
contrast the fictional portrayal of
espionage against the reality of living
a double life in his new book the great
game
the program is an hour good evening my
name is Zachary Scholes and on behalf of
the owners and all the staff here at
politics and prose I'd like to welcome
you this evening and thank you for all
coming out we're very fortunate to have
with us Frederic and he hits speaking to
us about this his newest book the great
game the myth and reality of espionage
mr. hits educated at Princeton and
Harvard Law School entered the CIA as an
Operations Officer in 1967 he left the
CIA in 1973 worked for the department's
of state defense and energy and then
returned to the CIA as a legislative
counsel to the director and deputy chief
of operations in Europe in 1990 he was
appointed the first statutory Inspector
General of the CIA in which capacity he
served until his retirement in 1998
since then mr. heads has taught at the
Woodrow Wilson School at Princeton
University he is going to speak to us
this evening for about a half an hour
followed by a period of
question-and-answer and then an
opportunity to have books signed if
during the question and answer period
you could direct your questions to the
audience mic which is right back there
so that everyone can hear the question
and for the convenience of those filming
please join me in welcoming Frederick P
hits
well what a treat I see a lot of
familiar faces so when the time comes
for you to throw the ripe fruit after I
take questions please do it and with
accuracy I think a word might be in
order about the provenance of this book
I was the Inspector General at CIA from
92 98 which is about long enough time to
be an inspector general many of my
colleagues would have said too long but
that's another issue
and I began to cast about towards the
end of that term to find a situation and
to write a book and I went to the Dan
Dean of the Woodrow Wilson School Mike
Rothschild and I said Mike who who was
fool enough to fund somebody in my
situation he thought about it for a
couple of weeks and invited me to come
up and write the book at Princeton and
that's where I've been since not looking
back
frankly if it took me a fair amount of
time to get geared up and write this
book I had in mind when I first inquired
of him that I would produce yet another
tome on how to reform intelligence or
make it better and after a long
conversation with my agent Ron Goldfarb
he said there's so doggone many of those
books hanging around most of them on
shelves gathering dust why don't you do
something that relates to the seminar
you're teaching freshman Princeton has a
Freshman Seminar program as most
institutions do trying to break down the
size of classes for incoming students so
many of them are big survey courses are
dealing with requirements they want to
give students an opportunity to see the
method of instruction or the size of
instruction they're likely to see in
their succeeding years so the Freshman
Seminar program which they couldn't give
away in the beginning has attracted a
number of faculty members who have a
chance to teach something wacky
a little bit offbeat not go through the
curriculum thought-control process and
it since become a very popular affair
and I thought maybe it would be fun
since I have loved spy novels since I
don't know when to give a course give a
seminar in which using the best works of
spy literature 'the best by my lights as
the template i would compare it to the
real thing so that's what i've attempted
to do in this small volume and i've done
it on a topical basis i write about such
things as recruitment you can't get
intelligence unless you recruit spies I
write about betrayal in essence when a
person spies for another country he is
in fact betraying that country betraying
his own country probably probably his
friends and family as well and over a
period of time that weighs heavily on
the character of about any but the most
hardened individual let me just stop for
a moment and define my terms I'm talking
in this book about espionage which is a
discrete subset of what we generally
regard as intelligence it may be the
oldest form it goes back to biblical
times obviously but it is of course only
a part of what we pay 38 to 40 billion
dollars a year for in the intelligence
world kim Philby who knew a thing or two
about espionage I think defined it
economically and in a way that I have
chosen to adopt he called it espionage
the collection of secret information
from foreign countries by illegal means
each of those phrases is a term of art
if you will its secret information
you're not cutting out news
paper clippings although in a number of
the good books that's what fabricators
did and got paid pretty well for it
we're talking about spying on foreign
countries we're not talking about
domestic secret stealing and we are
talking about stealing we're talking
about acquiring this information not in
the ordinary course but taking it I call
the book the great game that's a term
known to many of you with reference to
the British Raj the attempt to maintain
their Dominion in South Asia from the
Hindu Kush to the coast and I really
begin this course with and I never
really end it with a love affair with
Kipling's Kim which as a as a side bar
note was written not in India or in
Britain but in Brattleboro Vermont he
shortly thereafter wrote Captains
Courageous he was on a visit to the
United States he'd married an American
woman he didn't really like the US he'd
met Teddy Roosevelt he thought he was a
bit of a character but all in all the
United States at that time wasn't his
cup of tea when he comes to the great
game he must go alone alone and at peril
of his head from time to time God causes
men to be born and thou art one of them
who have a lust to go abroad at the risk
of their lives and discover news today
it may be of far-off things tomorrow of
some hidden mountain and the next day of
some nearby men who have done a
foolishness against the state these
souls are very few and of these few not
more than ten are of the best we of the
game are beyond protection if we die we
die our names are blotted from the book
when everyone is dead the great game is
finished not before
so in trying to set it up in this
fashion recruitment first betrayal I'm
dealing with the essence of the contract
so to speak Licari wrote a book that is
sort of different from most of the other
Cold War
masterful spy stories that he wove in
the earliest part of his career which
apparently is autobiographical in part
the father of Magnus Pym is in fact a
one-off of his own father who was a con
man but it's the strangest of his books
on this subject because it talks about a
sort of a psychological condition that
is only broken when that father dies
late in the book betrayal she said we
betray to be loyal
betrayal is like imagining when the
reality isn't good enough he wrote that
betrayal is hope and compensation as the
making of a better land betrayal as love
as a tribute to our unlived lives on and
on these ponderous aphorisms about
betrayal betrayal as escape as a
constructive act as a statement of
ideals worship as an adventure of the
soul well as I said a little bit earlier
betrayal which may begin as a contract
of spy services for money it may be an
act of outrage it may be an act of
thumbing your nose at others whom you
consider to be
less able than you but higher in the
chain of command it can be all these
things but over a period of time as a
way of law life it is difficult and
becoming more difficult and in the end a
number of the people that I've written
about in the book and whose real life
stories you may be familiar with as well
tired of the game and almost seemed
ready to be captured or ready to have
the dual identity end peter Popoff who
was one of America's great volunteers in
the 50s a GRU officer who was a Russian
peasant through and through grew up in a
hovel with a dirt floor in the Ukraine
but was smart and pushed by others in
his family he had a good war the Great
Patriotic War and he was able to get
himself into the Front's of Military
Academy and get officer rank but he
never got over his hatred of the NKVD
the Soviet secret police and when the
opportunity came to betray them he did
he carried out of the embassy in Vienna
which was the old him imperial hotel a
an order of battle chart as big as that
as as big as your wingspan which you
could barely concealed under his tunic
once he began to work for the US he
began the business by tossing a note in
the backseat of an automobile asking for
a a meeting after he had been a
productive agent for a good many years
he still had not followed fully the
instructions of his spy runner his case
officer said he had originally come to
the u.s. at least in part to get money
because his Serbian mistress was having
a baby and he was told ok we'll pay the
money but
you've got to break off with her you're
married this nothing but trouble you're
going to come to the view of the
authorities and at the very least you'll
be chucked out of the country and not be
able to help much
well stubborn as he was he never
listened to that advice he broke off his
contact on several occasions for God his
contact instructions approached the
British military attache in Germany on a
on a walk-in basis classic case of
somebody who was reckless in the extreme
the same argument was made about Aldrich
Ames who happens to have been a class
mine in the career training program at
CIA but a person who made over four
million dollars with his espionage but
made no effort to conceal the amount of
money that he had he bought a house for
cash in Arlington County he's four and
fifteen and twenty thousand dollars
through his credit card accounts each
month and failed to write contact
reports the memoranda of meeting with
his Soviet agents as if he just was
above it all and finally if you can't
help read the case about the case of
Robert Hansen the FBI spy without sort
of shaking your head here was a person
who was a member of a very conservative
Catholic order Opus Dei educating his
children in Opus Dei schools private
schools which cost him money which he
was getting from the Soviets for his
secrets and continuing to espouse on the
job a hard-line anti-communism but
willing to get every bit of information
he could possibly scarf up he was an IT
specialist into the hands of the
Russians and yet never feeling he had
dictated the terms of his contact with
the Soviets he never saw his case
officer in person his spy Runner in
person he serviced dead-drops with the
information but
if you read the documents that the US
government introduced into the criminal
proceeding after he was caught you can
see the loneliness I don't think you
appreciate all that I'm doing for you
and finally in the end when he was
apprehended by one of his colleagues at
the FBI he said what took you so long so
it's a strange business in reviewing the
literature I begin as I say with Kim and
then the secret agent and a riddle of
the sands which is a marvelous sea story
and you're really talking about a
element of the genre where spies were
Patriots they were volunteers they were
the center of focus they were the
protagonists as you move into the 30s
and 40s however in the spy war against
fascism and eventually against Soviet
Communism
the organizational aspect of it becomes
important and you find in authors like
Catholic RA and his masterful Aspire
came in from the call the question being
raised perhaps in pursuing the tactics
that the spy agencies have to to get
information out of the Soviet Union we
are in fact defying our own
constitutional liberties and our own
approach to the rules of civilization
we're becoming so much like them we
manipulate people in the same fashion
that they're in lekars view and Graham
Greene's view from time to time there's
not a dimes worth of difference between
the two systems and the way that they
treat their personnel I try to deal with
counterintelligence which is really the
subject matter for most of the best spy
stories George Smiley was a
counterintelligence man before anything
else I deal with tradecraft operational
security how people go about their job
and of course I deal with the whole idea
of spies and sex it well they all come
into the course thinking they're going
to get a lot of James Bond but they
don't they do get this though From
Russia With Love at delicious passage
when Tatiana Romanova if you've seen the
film is being prepared by Rosa Klebb who
was played by Lotte Lenya the stewed
prune dried up little lady who was a
raging homosexual herself and she speaks
to Tatyana in the following way for the
next few weeks you will be most
carefully trained for this operation
until you know exactly what to do in all
contingencies you will be taught certain
foreign customs you will be equipped
with beautiful clothes you will be
instructed in all the arts of allurement
then you will be sent to a foreign
country somewhere in Europe there you
will meet this man you will seduce him
in this matter you will have no silly
compunctions your body belongs to the
state since your birth the state has
nourished it now your body must work for
the state is that understood yes comrade
colonel the logic was inescapable well
needless to say we don't have many young
women case offices that are willing to
play that role thank goodness so it's
not a technique that has been polished
and perfected in the West
I talk about the subject of
assassination about which I feel very
strongly against and I talk it let me
just end it up here so I want to save
you something for the thrill of reading
it as I said earlier there's more to
espionage than a fee for services
revenge anger whatever may be the
extensible reason for an individual
becoming a spy after period of time if
you read these works carefully you'll
see that the game for the game amounts
to something it's very hard to explain
for example why Anthony Blunt one of the
Cambridge five chose to be a principal
recruiter among his colleagues for the
Soviet intelligence service as you
probably recall Blount was one of the
great art historians of his time he
really incorporated that cultural skill
that that body of learning from European
universities into British universities
he still regarded as perhaps the most
highly thought of authority on Pusa as
anybody but he worked furiously with guy
Burgess and outrageous but brilliant
homosexual at Cambridge to recruit
bright young men including Michael
straight an American citizen who
recently died dear friend of mine from
the highest ranks of the of the elite in
Trinity College Cambridge and elsewhere
after the war after the second world war
his career as an art historian consumed
him he essentially broke off but for a
time it was only possible to explain the
way he behaved himself as a person who
liked being in the know and maybe as
walter mitty sense really being in
control
matters that others didn't know anything
about that and the fact that he and
Philby and the number of the others were
notorious anti-american anti Americans
in their political sentiments so let me
just conclude with a passage that I
think describes the game for the game in
its most exotic aspect
once again from Kim his nickname through
the wards was little friend of all the
world and very often being live and
inconspicuous he executed commissions by
night on the crowded house tops for
sleek and shiny young men of fashion it
was intrigue of course he knew that much
as he had known all evil since he could
speak but what he loved was the game for
its own sake the stealthy prowl through
the dark gullies and lanes the crawl up
a water pipe the sounds and sights of
the woman's world and the flat roofs and
the headlong flight from house top to
house house top under cover of the hot
dark the man could write well it's not a
long book I think some of you who may be
spy novel aficionados will have read a
number of them I don't think you've read
them all and on that basis let me stop
nattering I'm willing to take questions
on
intelligence issues beyond just those
that I've raised with you today
that's a Dearing a daring statement so
sir
well since he opened it up to a broad
question of course an answer I would
like to look at the big picture for a
second I mean CIA has had really huge
failures going back to Bay of Pigs and
before and of course the fall of Soviet
Union and East Germany and of course
more currently 9/11 what what do you see
or what efforts have been made to reform
it and make it more effective and do you
see this as happening this time after
9/11 well I have even a broader thank
you for that question I haven't even a
broader swath that I take on that issue
we've had intelligence failures in our
country since Pearl Harbor and during
the Cold War alone with the issue of the
attack on South Korea by the north the
development by the Soviet Union of an
atomic weapon which occurred much sooner
than we had anticipated with other
developments of that kind there has been
a points at which our intelligence just
didn't get it and in point of fact if
you examine it very closely you made
reference for example to the fall of the
Soviet Union it was an issue of belief
there in part not just taking this as a
discrete example our intelligence
coverage was very good the scientific
and technological aspects of the Soviet
war machine that we needed to know
something about with all of the nuclear
missiles pointed at the United States we
just didn't understand that they
couldn't make a toaster or couldn't plug
in an electric fan and this kind of
failure to fully understand that their
society was not working fully was shared
by most of our Western allies which
doesn't excuse it but to fast
forwarded into the situation that's on
everybody's mind the whole issue of 911
and what we might have known beforehand
and more particularly since in the war
in Iraq with the belief that Saddam
possessed stocks of weapons of mass
destruction all of us were running from
the same sheet of music we looked at
what to take the Iraq issue first we
looked at what the United Nations
inspectors had reported in 98 accounted
unaccounted for weaponry and we
extrapolated that anybody who had begun
the programs that Saddam had begun would
continue on in a certain way towards
creating a nuclear capability none of it
excuses a gap but it tends to explain it
and again that information was no better
as it flowed into the intelligence
agencies in Israel or Germany or Britain
which had after all had a presence in
that country at one time in the past or
France but I don't happen to believe
that the intelligence in the context of
and I'm with I really don't want to go
down this track so I probably shouldn't
mention it but I don't think the
intelligence on WMD was the final
decision point for the United States
going in I think we had a determination
to do that now how do you make it better
what I fear I was speaking to one of my
former colleagues shortly before we
started this afternoon what I fear is
that in 2005 if we can wait that long
all of the things that the present 9/11
Commission are beginning to discuss the
potential for the creation of an mi5 the
idea of a Director of National
Intelligence the so-called intelligence
czar they're going to come right to the
floor and people going to think that
there is a structural way to deal with
this issue which I don't believe quite
simply I I go by the the notion it's the
people stupid you've got to get
high-caliber people going into
intelligence
how many of you saw the David Ignatius
column in the in the post today where he
takes his hat off to INR which quite
rightly has had an enjoy - an excellent
reputation certainly with respect to
Iraq for a good many years and they do
it as he noted there with people who
stay on the job for a considerable
period of time develop expertise and
they do it in a way that the rest of the
intelligence community would probably
consider to be undermanned but they're
pretty good so my hope is that when we
get around to making intelligence better
as you asked we will look at the quality
of the work we're doing and ask the hard
questions about languages cultural
expertise time on the job and member Jim
Woolsey used to say I don't want my
expert on Kazakhstan to be promoted out
of his expertise into managerial job I
want him to stay right on that case
these are the kinds of issues that it
seems to me to bear looking now I had
the privilege of sitting in a Harvard
chair which is pretty tough for a
Princeton man but I thought the Harvard
College of Arts and Sciences the Dean
last week came out with a terrific way
to express what will be the challenge
for this generation of students he said
if you want to come to Harvard you
better have a passport what I see among
the students that I teach is that we are
pushing them pushing them pushing them
pushing them to take summers abroad a
semester abroad anything that will get
them to dig deeply into a foreign
language and into another culture
because clearly if we're talking about
intelligence failures it's a national
figure we don't understand these people
we do not understand why they are in
such opposition to us and to Western
things and we've got to find out how and
I don't think we're going to do that
until number one we can converse with
them and number two have some
familiarity with the lives that they
lead I'm
reading auntie Carol's delicious little
book of the year ago on the way here I
mean she didn't speak any Arabic her she
found interestingly enough those of you
read it she found that her Russian was
pretty darned good in Iraq for a period
of time
when she was trying to get her bearings
but her instincts are so good and she
can see that this she could see before
the war began that Iraqis were beaten
down they hadn't any they couldn't stand
Saddam but they heard they had been
through this long period of of the
embargo they were had legions of people
who were underemployed or unemployed it
was not going to be it was clear just
for an astute person like that that the
notion of Americans arriving in an in a
in a liberating force was a lot of
nonsense you don't have to get espionage
information as this book speaks to to
get that answer sorry for the filibuster
sir that the I I did happen to notice
that article in the paper and I still
wonder if all of this that's going on is
saying that is is is the is good it's
hard to say whether to me I can't can't
see whether Iraq is right or wrong yet
from what I see I see lots of things
that say the State Department was right
and by saying that weapons of mass
destruction was not it I can see the
situation of saying that absent that
absence of evidence is not evidence of
absence right Rumsfeld Rumsfeld does
formulation and the president said it
all couple of weeks ago in his press
conference he still regards he was still
regards Saddam as having been a threat
irrespective of the of WMD that was his
that was his view and so and you can
make and you can make a good argument to
that effect but a lot of the
suppositions on which our invasion was
bottomed didn't have to occupy the
country in a in a in a in an adversarial
manner just didn't prove out and that we
a lot of things that might have happened
didn't happen the oil wells were not
destroyed they weren't massive refugee
throw floes that we had to provide for
but in point of fact the resistance to
an outside occupying force American or
British has just intensified and I think
what the president seemed to me to be
saying in the press conference was this
is the judgment I made and you know
you'll have a judgment to make on it
when your time comes but I don't want to
get too much bogged down and debating on
on the the merits of that I was just
trying to make the point about
intelligence which is that yes the
answers were not provided to the intent
by the intelligence community on this
particular issue but it was a much
broader failing just as
eleven was no and the president again
spoke to that nobody thought people
would capture a civilian airliner and
use it as a suicide weapon we've been
warned by Tom Clancy we'd been warned by
the French experience out of Marseille
but we really didn't in all of the
particulars that deal with it come to
grips with it sir the Israeli Mossad has
this vaunted
reputation now you feel they are really
that special in the great game the
Mossad does have a reputation and I
think because they're so much in the
middle of things and their survival
depends on their acuity they are
probably a very good service I didn't
have the responsibility of working with
them directly so this is just a horse
back opinion which is no better than
your own but the point is that I think
they're good I think they've also had
some difficulty and I think what gives
them a terrific advantage again is the
proximity I don't know this for a fact
not being an Arabist myself but my
understanding is you can move from
Hebrew to Arabic with a lot of hard work
pretty easily and they're their sources
in their ability to pass if you will
since obviously ethnically they're
they're very strong links is very strong
thank you
you see usually we're supposed to ask
one question but I had one fast one and
then a more serious one for the IG is
part of your job that you would
investigate intelligence failures or was
just just charges of legalities and
things like that were you given their
open-ended portfolio or immunity it's a
statute that pretty much gives the IG
the opportunity to look into matters at
his or her discretion and by that I mean
if it relates to we had three basic
areas of responsibility we did all the
auditing we looked at the books where
did the money go
we had responsibilities I have a
colleague of mine from those days
present here which I'm delighted about
but we also did inspections where the
notion was to see if we could isolate
best practices and urge those sort of
the in-house Booz Allen and then we had
the responsibility for investigations of
wrongdoing so on the intelligence
failure business if it was something
systemic if we if the organization was
not doing what it should have been doing
taking no was not living up to its
responsibilities yes we could have
looked into it okay so they the other
question was and we could have done it
irrespective of whether the Congress
asked us to do it or the director of
Central Intelligence we could do it on
our own hook the other question was the
US has had immigration you know all
forever at in the 70s there were already
lots of people coming out of the Soviet
Union there's a tremendous error
population in the United States of
several million that have come from the
Middle East countries and I'm wondering
and of course you also have academics
who I read one calls website and he
seems to be very well informed and I
think it's good to perhaps your
bureaucrats who know all these languages
but in a country like the United States
there's plenty of expertise available
and everything you could you could want
and
one has to be a little creative in using
these resources too instead of building
creative is a very good word for it and
I think you probably know what some of
the drawbacks are if you are an ethnic
Arab in the United States but you have
relatives still in the region on a basis
of the security judgments made about
your file you often have trouble of
getting a clearance because there's some
concern that they will will be lingering
influenced I had a student at the
University of Virginia whose father was
still in Beijing and he had gone to
American high school gone to high school
in New York City tended to remain in the
United States and I think that he was
not granted a not given an offer simply
because the organization wasn't was
concerned about his father and the and
the potential pressure so I think the
creativity is the word to use I think
we're going to have to because our needs
are great not play this entirely by the
book but I'm the guy that looked into
the aims case and he Pat any and he was
helped through two polygraphs so I have
a little bit of a guilt complex on the
fact that the polygraph has become kind
of a make-or-break event but we I think
we need I think we need to make use of
these resources bill Fred it is my
recollection that for years and years
espionage used to be just having our guy
over there or one of their guys who is
prepared to to tell us about what was
going on over there and then we got all
this electronic stuff with spy
satellites and and listening in on
everything and I have the impression
that we pretty much let the personal
asset side of things slip is that
correct
did we let the personal asset side slip
and are we building that back up and do
we have to build that back up I
understand that we have very few people
in Iraq that we can
would you care to comment about the
relative balance between electronic
espionage and personal assets I think
it's a next question and I think it
wasn't so much a conscious neglect if
you want to put it that way of the fact
that our our our roles of spies were
diminishing what really happened bill
was that in 1991 with the fall of the
Soviet Union a lot of mature
intelligence officers looked at the new
'ti tables and said hey I've got I've
got another ten years we beat the
Russians I've got a couple of things I'd
like to do I'm out of here
and what and I daresay that happened in
the department as well that people had
had full careers doing what they were
doing during the Cold War and at that
particular time 91-92
didn't want to do drugs or our anti
crime fighting or some of the initial
law enforcement related kinds of things
that appeared to be what the
intelligence community was going to be
doing so in addition to closing down the
recruiting process for a time or
substantially slowing it down we also
had a number of unforeseen retirements
of very capable people and that's been
hard to catch up on at the same time and
again I had my toe in this particular
ball too and that was after the end of
the Cold War we needed to do kind of a
baseline check of who it was that was
reporting to us this is where the
Guatemala business camp comes in and
where the notion of human rights abusers
that has been so talked about in the
press and the notion that you if you're
going to have a person with a checkered
record on on crime or on human rights
abuse it would have to be vetted at the
highest level the agency that became an
excuse in the eyes of some for just not
pushing the point you're
bureaucratic resistance a risk aversion
it was called so there's a little bit of
this in that all along but mostly it was
a shifting gears I think now to get to
your last point yes my understanding is
that the roles of human source operators
is growing now I worry about it because
they're getting so doggone many resumes
that they and probably like the
Department of State they probably aren't
able to give the kind of attention to
each applicant that they ought to do I
look at the viewpoint from my own
students
luckily I've had nearly ten or a dozen
students in one way or another who've
gotten involved with the Foreign Service
or the agency in this time frame and
they're going in on an early basis and
they therefore can get hooked on the
business which is what one hopes happens
but there are so many opportunities out
there for young people in these
first-class institutions whether it be
Virginia or Georgetown or Princeton or
Harvard whatever it may be that the
government doesn't seem to realize that
they're in this kind of a competition
where they've got to do something get
off their behinds and really make an
appealing pitch
what's my gonna career gonna look like
what might I be doing my they ever get a
chance to the future time to study for a
degree can I improve my languages will
you help pay for that how do I live
what's the money deal I've formed the
view that the only way to be really
successful in bringing people in is to
do it in the summertime do it on an
internship basis because then they don't
have a lifetime commitment at that point
the outfit can try to sell them on
what's going on and they can check on
this fellow he looks terrific on or he
or she looks terrific on paper but you
know isn't really the person we want the
trouble with that of course gets back to
the question of your predecessor of the
security clearance is time-consuming and
expensive so we don't have enough
internship slots in a lot of the places
that require access to classified
information
the final point the balance between the
human source and the technical there's a
tendency now you know nothing ever stops
in the middle in in America's approach
to things we're now down playing the
role of Technology because it was it's
argued we over we over relied upon it I
don't think so
I think the role of Technology
especially in this information
technology era maybe you're better at it
bill than I am but I just feel like a
absolute babe when I look at what can be
done in the IT world now and the
students that are coming on that have
that expertise I think we're going to be
able to it's going to be technology
forcing we're going to be able to do a
lot with in the information world that
will enhance what we know about other
places thank you two questions if I may
related to the defense CIA relationship
first and this one is just factual my
own ignorance but my recollection was
that when the agency was established
that the director of Central
Intelligence ntral intelligence was
conceived to be the overlord of all
intelligence services and
recommendations to the president so
what's different than the mi context
that is being looked at now but second
and perhaps more important to me I think
was in the nation article this morning
that he numerated something like 1,300
analysts within the CIA two to three
times that number within the DIA and
probably a budget of ten times the
number and what is the special role of
each to distinguish one from the other
and to what extent is the DIA consumed
in things that really consume a lot of
people in the technology area b2b
analysis well those were all good
questions let me see if I can start from
the beginning the issue of whether the
DCI was intended to be the overall
Czar of intelligence as you suggest
comes right from the 1947 act what's
ironic if you study the history as
President Truman opposed the creation of
CIA in the beginning he didn't he'd had
his hands full with with J Edgar Hoover
for a long time he didn't want another
American Gestapo and he was basically
talked into creating a civilian
Intelligence Agency not by Bill Donovan
who was a Republican Irishman from
upstate New York he might have had a
relationship with FDR but he didn't cut
much ice with HST and but he was
convinced by Pearl Harbor the absence of
warning and the notion that the studies
just after the war indicated that there
was information out there that had it
been collected in one place might have
been given us a clue a lot like the
arguments we've heard about 9/11 and so
he agreed to the creation of a Central
Intelligence Agency with a director that
seemingly had the power to task other
organizations on the analytical side it
wasn't even clear in the beginning
whether CIA was going to have a
collection capability which it clearly
did and then shortly thereafter with
George Kennan whose hundredth year we
just celebrated a month or so ago that
CIA was going to be asked to do the
covert action propagandizing and and
political operations but no director of
selim central intelligence with the
possible exception of Beatle Smith who
had a remarkable relationship with with
Truman as he did with Eisenhower and all
of the people in the Pentagon nobody as
a bin that DCIS job has been able to
crack the whip against the defense
intelligence agencies when the Secretary
of Defense would stand up and say the
chain of command is as follows and I'm
an effect not going to have a civilian
holding sway over my responsibility to
protect the force the armed forces of
the United States and I would suggest to
you even in the wake of these two
seeming quote intelligence failures when
they have a go at that argument
again in 2005 they're gonna hit the same
wall they sure as heck are with Don
Rumsfeld it's in my budget I'm I'm
looking after them but frankly there is
something to be said for that and the
Defense Intelligence Agency to which you
made reference their principal
responsibility is order of battle what's
going to be coming at us what are we
going to have to have to do in country
to protect the forces terribly important
job I don't know why the they need as
many analysts of they've got but that's
certainly a function that's going to be
continued Ignatius this column spoke to
INRs optic and INR can afford to rifle
shot it because they've got this vast
body of analysts who cover what's going
on in new Cabala ponga and they can
concentrate on those things that really
mean a lot to the Secretary of State and
they do a wonderful job of it but their
job is to keep the Secretary of State
primed to be the president's top foreign
policy adviser so that's what their
their major goal is CIA has been meant
to be the jack-of-all-trades the place
where all sources of intelligence come
together in daily report for the
president that has just been shared with
the legislative branch for and an
outside Commission for the first time
there any question in my mind that if we
put a little time and attention to to
how this should work as a teamwork
proposition we can do a better job now
what you haven't even talked about the
FBI's role and in this terrorist world
the relationship between the FBI
responsible for domestic keeping the
peace in this country the law
enforcement aspect of what is involved
in counter-terrorist activity is
enormous
CIA is prohibited by the 1947 act from
exercising domestic law enforcement
powers
that laws got to change point of fact we
are involved in domestic law enforcement
because we are part of the information
chain that starts in Hamburg in the
mosque in which Mohamed Atta was was was
pulling his band together to come to the
United States we gotta get some help
over there before they come here and if
we can put our arms around them we won't
want to be able to gather evidence that
we could use in an American a tribunal
for you were going to testify to so
we've got a lot of changes going on and
I couldn't defend the strength of any of
these places currently but we're gonna
have to give some time and attention to
to it and and make it work better not
necessarily change all of the wiring
diagrams and create another bureaucracy
we're gonna put in we're gonna create
another mi5 having just created the
Department of Homeland Security please I
don't want to step in in any toes but
that's you know that's a hundred and
seventy thousand people doing a lot of
different things and I'm not sure any of
us know how that's coming together
remembering that the Department of
Defense took decades before it really
worked
efficiently sir I questions one is it
seems to be probably the intelligence
community has some attitudes that are
strikingly different from the ordinary
intuitions of the man in the street for
example well there seems to be some kind
of a broad feeling that assassination is
not a good idea and I'm sure that most
casual readers of thrillers might not
might not agree and it seems that there
may be some different attitudes
that that that there may be some things
in which the community differs in
attitudes strongly from the average
publican maybe you could describe some
of those and also who's your favorite
spy novelist okay thank you for bringing
us back I hate to be caught on shooting
my mouth off on a lot of worldwide
topics where you have as good a judgment
of what's going on as I do but on the
issue of assassination I am very much
opposed to political assassination as a
tasking for America's civilian
intelligence agencies I just don't think
we intelligence officers are hired to do
that and I don't think they have any
competence in it and when they have been
asked to do it I'm talking I'm trying to
define my terms I'm talking about
political assassinations taking out a
head of a government in a in a peacetime
situation because we're opposed to what
he or she is doing or believe that
they're a threat to the United States I
just think that the cadre from whom one
is drawing to teach them espionage how
to collect information doesn't have any
expertise in in arranging for
assassinations and all you have to do is
read the church committee record which
was still a very very readable and
accurate portrayal the efforts at
eliminating Castro were just lugubrious
they were so you know powder in his
beard stuff in his wetsuit toxins the
sand so it was like
one of green greens more far-fetched
entertainments and the fact of the
matter is the President of the United
States wanted this to occur Bobby
Kennedy after the Bay of Pigs disaster
was riding herd on CIA to come up with a
scheme to eliminate Castro as a major
priority of our government and it just
wasn't something that the intelligence
world was equipped or inclined to do so
I would say let's not change the
executive order ban on political
assassinations leave it the way it is
and recognize that in this war on
terrorism in which we're engaged
depending on how the supreme court
handles a number of the cases that
they've got to decide this spring it
will be possible to worry about somebody
like Saddam on the basis of the laws of
war rather than anything that is sort of
a contracted for assassination business
now what was my favorite a spy author
yes I've been accused of being too much
of a Euro file here but I think if I had
to you know I had only one spy book to
read or one author to choose from I'd
have to go to Graham Greene
I think the quiet American was a far
better book than a movie although it was
an excellent movie the one that I
feature in my book the human factor is
probably not read all that much it's an
absolutely masterful story did you like
it so that's the one if you if you look
Harry is close but I'd say Graham Greene
man yes I know that you have touched
upon the issue of foreign languages
earlier however which issue is the most
crucial to tackle is it interpretation
is it translation is it the gathering of
bringing together a quote unquote
linguist although the world linguist has
been really misused because a linguist
is not necessarily someone who speaks
another language it's usually someone
who knows about the history of language
of the and the roots of languages so
what is the problem I mean is it mostly
interpretation translation well I'm sure
having people who speak the language I'm
sure it's that latter point and I mean I
think any intelligence officer if they
were candid would say that they woke up
on September 12th and they said oh my
goodness when they begin to look through
how this occurred the one thing we don't
want to be presented with was the fact
that we had some intelligence in in a
foreign language when we hadn't
translated the intercept or whatever it
may have been and it might have been
giving us a clue I don't think we found
that sort of smoking gun so to speak
thank goodness since but translation is
still terribly important but what I'm
getting at is language as a way to get
to know other peoples and cultures I
think it is a real deficiency that the
United States has borne for too long
because the oceans have really separated
us and kept us on our own
a little part of the world yes thank
goodness Spanish is now in some areas of
the country almost offered in a in a
bilingual way to English should be but I
think we've got to go harder and and
more deeply into it because if I have my
vision of it
if this Harvard Dean was right every
Harvard student better have a passport
those students are going to gain so much
by getting out and understanding how
others think live want to live what
their their value judgments are and
that's what I'm in other words it ain't
just for espionage it's for the nation
as a whole it certainly can be used for
intelligence gathering down the road but
I think our country is finding ourselves
we're finding ourselves really quite
startled by the extent to which we don't
understand what's going on in some
places that are fairly important to us
one more question of I exhausted you
language what about religion don't we
need to have a better understanding of
other the other world's religions isn't
that another way that people are I agree
and I must say I'm buffaloed I'm sure
I'm not alone in this room I'm trying to
understand Islam in the wake of 9/11 try
and just understand what what how how it
can be that such a number of people find
a basis in their own religion for
suicide bombing and I you know is there
no hierarchy and the answer is
apparently not that condemns this kind
of activity out of hand so we've got to
find out more about what motivates
others in that regard well thank you all
for coming on Fredrik it's is a
professor at the Woodrow Wilson School
of Princeton University the great game
is published by Knopf visit Random House
com / Knopf for more information the
Zanzibar chest is Reuters correspondent
Aidan Hartley's mem